If you're still here, I assume that
means you've decided that you are ready
for this machine learning
engineering nano degree program.
In which case, I welcome you again.
Before we get started, though,
let's talk a little bit about
what is machine learning?
Machine learning has been
described as a lot of things.
It's been described as the next natural
step for artificial intelligence.
It's been described as
applied statistics.
just advanced algorithms.
And in reality,
it's kind of all of these things.
Like artificial intelligence.
It's about processing some data and
understanding data and
reacting intelligently to it.
Like statistics, it's about applying
advanced formulas to really
make sense and compare and
evaluate and summarize data.
Like algorithms,
it operates on some data input.
It provides some output.
So, really machine learning
is about the next synthesis
of lots of different fields, it's
really the next natural evolution for
a lot of things you've
studied in the past.